[JOHN:] Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
[HANK:] Good morning, John.
It's really… not my best work.
[J:] We very nearly had actual brothers
on a hotel bed.
Hank, it's Question Tuesday, the day that we answer real
questions from real nerdfighters, and you are going to
have to figure out the theme of today's questions.
[H:] Oh, I like it. I didn't look. Okay.
[J:] What, in your opinion,
is the most beautiful word?
[H:] I like “penumbra.”
[J:] For me, it's “ongoingness.”
[H:] I don't like “twelfth.”
[J:] That's a hard one.
[H:] Twelfth.
[J:] What was the most foolish thing
you did as a child?
[H:] I remember getting in a lot of trouble
for throwing glass bottles off of our fort.
[J:] Hank, what do you think is the most beautiful
phenomenon in the Anthropocene?
[H:] I bet there's a couple colors that didn't
exist until we came around that are pretty good.
[J:] I was gonna say the understanding
of the speed of light.
[H:] That's good, too.
[J:] Hank, what is your all-time favorite
foolish endeavor? I have an answer for this.
My all-time favorite foolish endeavor is a
guy named Tony Hawks,
hitchhiked around the circumference of Ireland
with a refrigerator to win a bet,
and the book that resulted is
as amazing as you would hope.
[H:] That's a good foolish endeavor.
[J:] It is.
[H:] I was just gonna say
all of humanity.
[J:] Have you gotten the theme
of the video yet?
[H:] No.
I didn't yet. I didn't get the -
[J:] Are you serious?
[H:] No.
[J:] You seriously don't have
the theme of the video?
[H:] No.
[J:] Okay.
[H:] I wasn't paying a ton of attention.
What was it?
Favorite word?
And then there was like...
stupidest thing you done?
[J:] Mhmm....
I think everybody out there
has the theme.
[J:] This might get you to the theme.
[H:] Okay.
[J:] What is foolish -
[H:] Oh, okay. I got it.
[J:] Okay, finally!
What is foolish but also beautiful?
[H and J:] The internet.
[J:] And also...
[H and J:] Humanity.
[J:] Whaaaat.
[H:] And porcupines.
[J:] We were like, in a lock step.
[H:] Yeah.
[J:] The internet.
[H and J:] Humanity.
[H:] Porcupines.
[J:] I didn't have that one.
[H:] They're so beautiful.
[J:] I was gonna go, like, jalapeño poppers.
What is the best advice you ever got
from your kid?
[H:] Sometimes Orin will say,
"Feel happy."
[J:] That's good. That's helpful.
One time, one of my kids said,
“It's just YouTube.”
[HANK LAUGHS]
[J:] Are there any old school nerdfighterisms that
have made their way into your everyday language?
In the very first vlogbrothers video ever,
the camera turns off and you say...
[PAST HANK:] “Auto power off”?
There's still some glitches to work out.
[J:] And I say, “Auto power off, still some
glitches to work out” all the time.
Like, every time something goes wrong with
the camera 13 years later, I'll still be like,
“Auto power off,
still some glitches to work out.”
Is humanity worth saving?
[H:] Oh yeah.
[J:] Yes.
[H:] I've thought about this
a bunch, actually.
[J:] Right, it's sort of what you write about in your novels.
[H:] Yeah.
[H:] I think super yes.
[J:] Yes.
[H:] In fact, I will get into that conversation
fairly deeply in this book.
[J:] Great, I can't wait.
[H:] I'm almost done.
I will send it to you probably Monday.
[J:] Have you stayed in any hotel rooms as good as
the one that had that Picasso since 2012?
[H:] I've never, nope.
[J:] Not even close. We almost always stay
in Courtyard by Marriotts.
[H:] Thank you. There's actually a courtyard
in this one, which is unusual.
[J:] Hank, do you think that I should go back
to sports Twitter?
My Twitter account @sportswithjohn,
not regular Twitter?
[H:] I think you should do
what you want to do, John.
[J:] Since I left Twitter, Liverpool Football
Club have not lost a game in the Premier League.
So... why would I go back?
[HANK LAUGHS]
[J:] I'm the one who's making it happen!
[J:] What's the last movie that made you cry?
[H:] It was the last movie I saw,
which was Little Women,
which was very good.
[J:] Every movie makes me cry. Like, I haven't
seen Cats yet, but I'm sure it will make me cry.
[H:] I want to see Cats.
[J:] I don't.
[HANK CLEARS THROAT]
[J:] But I support people who do.
I'm not here to harsh on your yums.
If you like Cats, whatever, that's great. God, thank God
that somebody likes something somewhere.
[J:] Hank?
[H:] Mhmm?
[J:] I will see you, I will continue,
you know.
[H:] Yeah.
[J:] Alright.